So personality is a mixture of both nature and nurture. But the nurture part
ironically comes mostly from outside of the family. With twin studies, we see
that heredity, or your genetics account for around 50 to 60% of most traits.
However, slightly less for agreeableness and openness. What's surprising is
that shared environment, meaning your home and your family, has a really small
influence on these traits, as compared to a non sharing environment. So for
example you get 39% of your openness from your genetics, 14% from the
environment you share with your family. And 47% from your non-shared
environment. And as for conscientiousness, 44% of this trait comes from
non-shared environment with 56% of it coming from genetics. And we can see this
line up with extroversion, agreeableness and neuroticism as well.